when you talk about getting to denmark
america it seems like it takes an extra
decade or two
to get through these things if you look
at gay marriage and you look at
um cannabis regulation you know we're so
far behind on these things
and then it tips at a certain point no
this is what gives me such hope about
america
that uh for all the failings in america
there is
absolutely a willingness to change
not legal in denmark not legal in
denmark legal international in almost
all of europe there is crazy portugal
and and in in holland these things
there's either
uh decriminalizations or full-on
legalization it's not legal anywhere
else
and this has happened in the us in a
very relatively short
amount of time and this is what gives me
such hope and why i agitate so
lively for for all these advantages yeah
i know american can do this
and i know it particularly so because as
you said at the top of
of the start of this is america is
uniquely rich
you look at gdp per capita america just
trounces denmark it's more than 20
higher gdp per capita in the us than it
is in denmark
the money is here it's just being spent
very poorly
18 percent of gdp spent on health care
bonkers
right the fact that the the federal
government can't provide these services
is simply just a factor of taxation
the u.s collects something like 17
percent of gdp in taxes
compare that to france uh or denmark and
it's in the
in the mid to high 40s literally in
denmark we collect
three times the amount of gdp per capita
to provide these basic services to
society and what do you get
you get denmark is literally number two
on the list of
happiest people in the world number one
is finland which has a very similar
system to
yeah to denmark right and the u.s i
think is 19.
and if you just think about like also
when people get pregnant
and have babies you get time off
paid for by the government or by
companies how does it work
uh usually it's a bit of a combination
but yeah that's a great point because
this is really all of
western industrialized world has paid
uh parental leave the u.s has none like
literally
zero weeks assigned yeah in general
worker protections
you go to a place like denmark you get
six months off at full pay
and then you can take additional time
after that at reduced pay
and you're like i mean i have three kids
yeah
well we have three kids and i haven't
gone through that i just i can't even
imagine someone who has only like two
weeks
yeah to from when when they have a kid
until
the wife has to get back to work or the
partner who had the kid that has to get
back to work you go like
jesus that is just inhumane and why
why do we need that right so yeah that's
one area where
i'd actually give tech some kudos that
there's been some movement here on
policy that a lot of tech companies
actually have
quite generous parental leave programs
now
um obviously that should just be a
societally
yeah it should definitely tech companies
have these wide
generous policies for their treasured
unicorn employees their engineers their
designers the project management
they're not exactly giving these
benefits out to their gig workers or
their
center staff or any of the other worker
areas
perfect perfect